[Música]
já pararam para pensar como um fato uma
pessoa um acontecimento pequena às vezes
pode transformar completamente o futuro
de uma história no início da década de
um meteorologista americano chamado
edward lorenz fez uma simulação em um
programa de computador do movimento das
massas de ar
um dia ele alterou os números que
alimentavam o cálculo dessa máquina
mudando só alguns pouquíssimos decimais
ele achava que o resultado seria quase
que insignificante nas mudanças dos
movimentos da demasia o que surpreendeu
muito ele é que o resultado dos padrões
das massas de ar mudaram completamente
pra ele era como se o bater de asas de
uma borboleta no brasil pudesse algum
tempo depois causar um tornado no texas
baseado nisso ele formulou as equações
do chamado efeito borboleta que é uma
das bases da teoria do caos
a teoria do caos em resumo para explicar
a ideia central é de que uma minúscula
mudança em um evento pode provocar
resultados drásticos no futuro
um exemplo disse que muita gente conhece
o steve jobs contou num discurso deles
tem ford numa formar em uma formatura de
graduação que quando ele estava na
faculdade ele resolveu cursar a
caligrafia só por curiosidade
ele não tinha esperança nenhum é que
aquilo fosse usado de algum modo prático
na vida dele
dez anos depois quando ele estava na
equipe que projetava um macintosh
aqueles conhecimentos de caligrafia
fizeram com que eles desenhassem a
tipografia de computador mais bonita do
planeta
o design da apple seria um diferencial
essencial para o sucesso
essa da empresa no mundo no início no
final dos anos 50
o meu pai nasceu em uma cidade no
interior de minas gerais
chamada abaeté quando meus avós
descobriram que ele era completamente
surdo
eles pensaram ao contrário dos outros
quatro irmãos mais velhos dele não vale
a pena ele pra escola
então ele é com passou a acompanhar o
meu avô todos os dias na roça
a minha mãe nasceu em outra cidade
a família da minha mãe na verdade é de
outra cidade do interior de minas
chamadas erro
e quando a minha mãe nasceu aqui em bh e
eles descobriram que ela também era
surda completamente surdo eles ficaram
muito em dúvida sobre a educação dela
quando minha mãe ia completar sete anos
a minha vó descobrir uma escola em são
paulo onde eles ensinavam meninas surdas
a falar era uma escola interna e minha
mãe e minha avó pensou assim eu tenho
que criar essa menina para o mundo então
vou mandar ela para essa escola
o meu avô discordou completamente ele
falou assim é louca você não pode
abandonar sua filha assim uma surda
nunca vai aprender a falar mas minha voz
e insistiu e mesmo obrigada com o meu
vôo levou à minha mãe para são paulo
onde ela matou minha mãe de 15 em 15
dias minha avó ia para são paulo visitar
minha mãe e ouviam meu avô falando que
ela estava indo para são paulo só pra
passear porque ela não tinha paciência
com a minha mãe porque ela era surda e
que minha mãe jamais aprender e ia falar
um ano depois minha mãe voltou pela
primeira vez para passar as férias
escolares
aqui na cidade quando ela voltou me avó
pediu para que minha mãe seja joelho ace
e minha mãe começou a rezar de maria na
frente do meu avô falando foi a primeira
coisa que ela aprendeu a falar meu avô
começou a chorar convulsivamente minha
mãe cresceu junto com meu pai teve três
filhos
eu que fagner mina o toninho ea helena a
habilidade de falar ajudou a minha mãe
a convence as a diretora de uma escola
incrível do nosso bairro anos dá uma
bolsa de estudos para 93 e aí a gente
tinha uma bolsa quase que integral mas
tinha um valor parcial que era quase
simbólico
meus avós morreram e deixaram algumas
terras no céu e ao redor es para os
filhos e herança
lanús e ruth um boato uma lenda de que
essas terras valiam muito por causa da
mineração
algumas pessoas sabiam outras pessoas
desconfiavam outras pessoas não tinham
ideia a minha mãe tava nesse terceiro
grupo de desinformados existiam existe
na verdade na época um famoso grande
empresário brasileiro que ele tinha
certeza sobre o valor dessas terras como
ele conseguiu essas informações
privilegiadas
ninguém sabe mas muita gente desconfia
esse empresário contratou um
testa-de-ferro serrano que iniciou a
compra dessas terras
paralelamente a isso a gente tinha cerca
de oito anos eu tinha meu irmão tinha
9.000 irmã tinha 7 estava na 3ª série
minha mãe mesmo com a bolsa quase
integral não conseguia mais pagar a
escola e resolvemos nos mudar para a
escola pública
quando ela conseguiu a vaga ela
precisava do histórico da escola privada
e era um procedimento comum é um
procedimento comum das escolas e
plausível que só se libere o histórico
com a quitação da dívida e minha mãe
precisava do histórico para matricular
gente na escola pública veio a oferta
deles pagarem a dívida na escola em
troca dela transferir as terras
ela aceitou na hora porque pra ela
prioridade à educação dos filhos dela eu
sabia o tanto que a educação foi
importante na vida dela e transferiu e
eles foram lá e pagaram a dívida da
escola era um mil reais mil reais
algum tempo depois minha mãe descobriria
que o valor real dessas terras poderia
pagar nossa educação pelo
estudar a vida de nosso 36 do bater das
asas de uma borboleta
como de tudo porque a gente foi pra
escola pública
dez anos mais tarde eu pude ser
matriculada na escola do sebrae no plug
minas um projeto social cujo pré
requisito necessariamente tinha que ser
você é aluno de escola pública porque eu
estudei na escola de sebrae
eu conheci o guia apoia brand luiz que
hoje são cogestores junto comigo de uma
organização que cho ninha e coloca a mão
na massa para transformar a realidade
das escolas públicas no país porque a
gente fundou a organização eu vi o tanto
que eu tinha interesse impacto e
conhecia a gabi a caron que hoje são
meus sócios no negócio social porque eu
estudei lá no clube eu conheci o gabriel
que citou uma frase do kennedy que eu
nunca esqueci que era 'não pergunte o
que um país pode fazer por você mas o
que você pode fazer pelo por um país
porque a gente foi pra escola pública
a minha dor com a desigualdade social
era tão forte tão lapentti que eu
resolvi fazer da causa da transformação
meu propósito de vida
o bater das asas de uma borboleta
muda tudo a primeira lição sobre o
efeito borboleta é que hoje cada um de
nós temos a vida que nós temos com todas
as dores e delícias que se implica por
causa de todos os fatos que aconteceram
com a gente
não dá pra gente pensar ah eu poderia
descartar esse fato do passado porque
quem a gente é hoje o tom o vôo o lugar
que a gente está hoje ele é um conjunto
de fatores a gente não consegue isolar
esses fatos e é por isso que quando a
gente tem que agradecer pelas coisas
boas que a gente tem na vida pelas
pessoas que a gente é gratuito
a gente não pode descartar desse
agradecimento às adversidades que a
gente viveu porque foram elas que nos
trouxeram
o que nós estamos hoje algumas pessoas
criticam quem tem uma visão de vida
assim que a valoriza o que aconteceu de
bom e de ruim como poliana de uma forma
pejorativa
poliana é o personagem de um clássico da
literatura infanto-juvenil que jogava um
jogo chamado jogo do contente onde
quando sempre acontece alguma coisa ruim
ela tentava ver o lado bom da quilo
algumas pessoas interpretaram a poliana
como a personificação do trouxa que
consegue ver coisas boas até nas coisas
ruins mas na verdade o que falavam no
livro poliana não se difere muito do que
os artefatos é considerado um pessimista
fala quando ele afirma a fase não
importa o que a vida fez com você o que
importa é o que você fez do que a vida
fez com você
voltando aos de ao início dos anos 60
meu pai tinha 10 anos de idade e nunca
tinha pisado em uma escola e seguia indo
todos os dias na roça como eu vou
um dia um primo do meu avô foi visitar
abaeté e viu meu pai interagiu com ele e
falou edigardo esse menino não pode
ficar na roça ele tem que ir pra escola
porque ele não está na escola e aí eu
vou falar ou não simão isso aí é muito
difícil não tem escola pra chuva ou não
a gente se hoje é difícil pensar em
inclusão para deficiente imagina e 60
anos atrás e os irmão insistiu falou de
gado
esse menino é muito inteligente ele não
pode ficar na roça
meu avô não quis dar ouvidos falou que
não existia a escola
minha vó descobriu uma única escola que
existia no rio de janeiro chamada
inicial era para alunos surdos e aí o
meu avô falou que não tinha dinheiro e
eles conseguiram uma bolsa para o meu
pai
e aí meu avô apesar de estar muito
pegado com o meu pai não tinha mais
desculpas meu pai aos 11 anos de idade
pisou pela primeira vez em uma escola e
foi detectado que a inteligência dele
era tanto
ele passou a fazer um ano escolar em
seis meses
passaram se anos meu pai foi estudar foi
convidado para participar de um curso de
liderança em uma universidade dos
estados unidos pra focada em surdos
meu pai voltou e liderou com outros
surdos daqui do brasil
o movimento que tornou a libras a língua
brasileira de sinais dos surdos
a segunda língua oficial do brasil e com
esse movimento eles conseguiram vários
direitos importantes para os surdos o
bater das asas de uma borboleta
muda tudo a segunda lição sobre o efeito
borboleta é sobre fazer a diferença que
o simão lá atrás não tivesse insistido
pra meu pai pra escola talvez alguns
direitos dos surdos retardariam a ser
conquistado e meu pai faria na roça até
hoje
às vezes a gente deixa de fazer alguma
ação de querer fazer a diferença porque
a gente fala assim a isso não vai mudar
o mundo isso vai ser muito pequeno e
isso não vai fazer a diferença
só que um mundo pautado pelo caos tudo é
significante tudo é importante a gente
deixa de mudar o mundo porque a gente
acha que isso não vai mudar mas qualquer
coisa que a gente fizer qualquer ação
não tem a possibilidade de mudar o mundo
já mudou o mundo se a gente entender se
o poder das nossas ações individuais a
gente faria muito mais porque o pod o
bater das asas de uma borboleta
muda tudo obrigada
[Música]